About 40 kilometers from the northernmost tip of Hokkaido In no time at all,
here
was the village where your father, Will Ward, was born.  I want to
know what kind of person he is and why I painted a pair of them
And the taste is really only I can solve When I woke up the key I
need to know
If there's something like that, I'll ignore it, maybe I'll be able to
remember something silly.  Hey, I'm
going to go to Karafuto, two countries, and I'm going to
work.
Shi 3 masa
kei I have to do something w I
found it in the gold coins of the stars of this game
Then
Ashika-san's beautiful debt
is reflected in the proof that I'm alive
[music]
gerber
2 tar
[music]
[  music]
was in shape